[Music]
baran a pit samurai against vikings
against nice in a male heir focus
battlefield over the next few days we'll
be looking at each faction and eight
ways you can straight-up murder off
walls we'll even throw in a little bit
of history so you can impress your
friends first up is the samurai led by
Ken say have you ever heard someone says
thug life like they're some sort of
gangster well Ken say would say Bushido
which means samurai life kenzie is a
heavily armored warrior who is agile and
carries a no touchy and Adachi is a long
sword considered by many to be soo
massive of real combat but can see it
begs to differ and the results are
devastating this is easily the most
rounded samurai character you have to
choose from so it's a perfect starting
point these other interests are
decapitating people too
next up is an aboushi who were
originally defenders of villages in
feudal Japan light on armor look very
quick and agile the range of their
weapons keeps their enemy at bay they
may not look like seasoned warriors but
believe me they have acrobatic skills
which will don't found you the Nauvoo
she can revive teammates far quicker
than any other and are perfect for
control matches but we warns they are
difficult to master but when you do
matter them you'll be decapitating Falls
regularly over to the RET these are
probably the Warriors that spring to
mind when someone says samurai these
Warriors are set up to counter-attack
and force enemies off balance their
light attack ultra fast and the
heightened block function allows for
heavy counter attacking the original
like their enemies to get back to their
feet so expect to find many heads
popping off in the battlefield finally
let's look at the sugar key who are all
about strength and for one don't expect
to be bounding around the battlefields
belong with this brute but do expect to
have devastating attack which will take
a while to hit the target but when they
do they will make short work of
everything their weapon of choice isn't
based around skill but my gosh it hits
hard the best bit about this character
you can kill someone by sitting on them
I don't know about you but I've dreamed
about that for many years okay so that's
a quick look at the samurais were Honor
I have already pledged my allegiance to
the samurai but who do you support
Vikings tonight please let me know below
I'll do it there but give us a like and
maybe think about subscribing we could
really do we all support i'm adam from
playstation grenade and i'll see you
next time